I interviewed the Syrian president in
2013 after a previous chemical weapons
attack was blamed on the Assad regime
will it be attacks against American
bases in the Middle East if there's an
airstrike you should expect everything
you should expect everything not
necessarily through the government is
not only the government's are not only
not the only player in this region you
have different parties you have
different factions you have different
ideology you have everything in this
solution now so you have to expect that
expect tell me what you mean by expect
everything expect every action including
chemical warfare that depends in this
region or any other group have it it
could happen I don't know we don't are
not fortunate a fortune-teller to tell
you what's going to happen in Burma is
pounding president of Eurasia group a
global risk consulting company welcome
let's see you give me a sense of what
the implications of this action by this
president are beyond Syria in terms of
China North Korea and how the rest of
the world sees Donald Trump well I mean
this is the first time that the foreign
policy establishment and pretty much the
entire constellation of American allies
are getting on board with a foreign
policy action by President Trump we've
seen it from the Canadians the Germans
the Saudis the Israelis we've certainly
seen it from both Democrats and
Republicans in the United States so as a
one-off attack you're not going to see
significant pushback by the Syrians they
have no capability to do so it feels
good and I think you know there's a
reason to do it but let's keep in mind
that if the United States had not
responded to these chemical attacks by
the Syrian regime no one else was going
to that's a good reason to do it it's
also a good reason not to do it there's
a reason why Obama agonized over not
taking this decision Trump didn't
agonize he just kind of pulled the
trigger and that's precisely because now
that Trump is saying what he wasn't
saying before that Assad the Assad
regime needs a quick transition out of
power there's no way for the u.s. to
affect that taking out one air base
isn't going to accomplish that the
Russians are clearly not on side with
the United States here the
the Iranians are the ones with the
military force you think it's my name I
think that if it turns out that it's
just actually the one off strike and
they don't continue down a very slippery
slope into a military engagement with
the Syrians then I don't think it's a
mistake but it's going to be incredibly
difficult for Trump now having changed
policy toward Syria to resist the
inexorable pull into a complete quagmire
let's be very clear
Trump is pulling back on foreign aid
Trump is pulling back on support for the
State Department Trump is not someone
who's interested in supporting refugees
with the exception of this these series
of bombs this is not a present that in
any way it showed an inclination to try
to engage from a humanitarian
perspective to help the people the over
500,000 that have died the millions that
have been displaced by this conflict I
don't think that changes with a series
of 59 Tomahawk missiles that would use
yesterday Syria is home to Russia's
largest military base outside of Russia
correct this morning The Associated
Press wires coming out Russia suspends
deal with us to prevent mid-air
incidents Russia says it's going to help
Syria strengthen its air defenses how
does this change our relationship with
Russia when Trump came in the single
thing he wanted to do is greatest at
odds with the Obama administration was a
rapprochement with Putin now of course
that's been undermined for all sorts of
reasons over the course of the last
couple of months but it is over now
right I mean you know Putin directly
condemned these strikes the Kremlin has
directly condemned these strikes and the
potential if the US were to further
expand its military engagement Syria the
Russians want to make clear that the
potential for direct confrontation
between the US and Russia is significant
now I don't think the Americans are
planning on taking that risk Trump as
president or no but the fact is that the
Russians are a significant antagonist of
the USN us-russia relations have
deteriorated more in the last 24 hours
than in any period that we saw under the
Obama so just Putin have more to gain by
coming back at the Americans and trying
to respond in some significant way or
since
letting this pass I think they've made
the statements that they need to make
the Russians have made clear that from
their perspective this was not the
Syrian government using chemical weapons
it was them hitting a Depot and the
rebels had these weapons themselves and
they have as just suggested suspended
the air cooperation where the United
States and Russia are trying to
deconflict the area that's a significant
statement but look the Israeli
government has engaged in one-off
strategic strikes against the Syrians
before the Russians have functionally
done nothing this is very similar if the
United States is the world's only
superpower chooses that it wants to go
in drone strike or bombs bomb a country
around the world
we can do that no one's gonna stand up
to us on that but that's very different
than Trump saying we now want Assad out
there's no mechanism for Trump to get
Assad out so this is a sugar high and
that that reflects Trump's diet and
reflects the way he's engaged in this
policy but you know in a month's time in
three months time US engagement in Syria
is not going to look like it has a win
at all and to the extent that Trump
actually embraces I want to do something
in Syria that's not why he's based voted
for him and it's also not gonna prove a
foreign policy victory of the United
States so this is being described in
it's his first international crisis how
do you think he's doing oh I think that
the decision to let the Russians know
right in advance was the single smartest
thing he has done in terms of foreign
policy I think the fact that he had the
right people in the room that mattis was
engaged he didn't you know sort of
Hillary Clinton was suggesting yesterday
let's take out all of the airfields
Frank I thought that was incredibly
irresponsible of Hillary to do it would
have risked a significant Russian
response would have forced their hand
this was actually limited it was
tactical it seemed commensurate to what
the Syrians were doing the only thing
that I'd say that's profits thoroughly
problematic that we need to think about
as a country is that apparently it is
okay for the Syrians to government to
have killed some 500,000 civilians with
conventional means we don't respond to
that but hit them with chemical means
we're gonna respond is that really the
message we want to send globally because
that is what the policy is so it's
different when you see the pictures
though you see the pictures and that
changes everything I've seen pictures of
Syrian refugees wash
up on the shores of New York and I
didn't see us respond to that right
thank you murmur thank you it's always
good to see you